I don't know where you are we'd know you
wouldn't I'm pretty well hidden
I found you hahahahaha you went to the
same place that I did my first time oh
poor little lady burning honeyBun
what do you mean that's the same place I
went to do you know where I am
yeah I was looking at right at you
you're so lucky Bob didn't find you all
wait you're spectating I forgot yeah
yeah how do you know all this
oh no it's hey don't give up so easily
Bob why don't you have a lie down huh oh
come on Bob Bob no no go back
hence all their beds no one's y'all lie
down on the couch you can become the
couch no Krista Oh God there you go
why can't I become you toilet I've
always wanted to be a toilet you kind of
were with your last comment but uh oh
wait remember there's an upstairs and a
downstairs oh boy hi Wade hi you see me
yeah I do
looking around like a loser walking
around like a loser leaving my room like
a loser coming back into my room like a
loser
see you don't you Richard downstairs
he's where I am I don't know if I think
it's a basement I think I am the
basement yeah yeah been really lose your
bye wait where are you I bet this room
I'm looking right
no I'm not over there's a horrible
mistake God by the bar where are you you
like to drink some bleach we're supposed
to be inside the house right that's the
deal yeah that's the deal how inside is
inside the rules you follow the bleach
there
oh my gosh I fell through a hole this
does this count mark I need I need a
ruling um ah you should be in how about
this does this count ha ha ha ha wow I
didn't I didn't even know you could do
that now there's no way we're definitely
not cheating wait probably probably not
Wade you want to go uh stretch your legs
in the Sun yeah baby bee bee bee bee bee
boo boo boo baby baby baby baby baby I
don't wanna look up no see how this is
unfair Bob you see this is fair I don't
understand what is hello God oh wait I
mean
wait that's for you mean Bob oh that's
not we should we'd be edge okay I'm
gonna go inside the house wait okay I
don't know what the devil's so funny ha
ha ha ha wait no no wait no no no wait
didn't you see the door that just opened
and closed no ha ha ha oh well if you're
honest
what the hell get to the door Bob really
I thought it would be ironic
is it as I can't go through the door
what'd yours go in the bathroom yeah at
bathrooms a hell hold on I got stuck in
there for like there you go two minutes
of this game you're good
Wow that sucked ah where'd you go Bob
I don't know where you went Jesus
Bobby's never gonna find you well I was
like Mary open right now
yeah kinda I guess Wade go watch some
television television eyes or some TV ad
or I've you know what I mean wait please
don't me saw that
that's one way to do it no did it Wade
did it it was he the first time he was
it a tree above you it was the douchiest
spot me he went on the roof and hopped
over it was just do sure but hilarious
that was that was not very fair but I'm
glad Markov some of it on video I did I
got it blade hmm
oh yes I thought well I'm gonna be next
time I really am
yes I'll get a drink Oh in the poor oh I
see you hello
what what was he only stool it didn't
fall over when I went like this oh those
are those deep way to find me all right
mark follow me I don't care down on you
all you come with me
coming I'm a really funny idea okay so
one of these yeah pick pick oh no you
can't be them okay okay
pick one of these pick the other one of
these okay follow me
oh my god I want to just test this out
oh my god
hey uh no over here over here I forgot
in here oh oh that's not the right place
uh where are you going up where's the
all over here over here only on time
okay come in here ah okay you beat oh
and then like over like this I don't
like okay that looks good there
how about this all right okay guys is
this oh do I look okay Bob where are you
no you look the line over there
we're supposed to be next to each other
oh I get you um well who are facing the
wrong way
haha just uh uh let's just go like this
like this perfect
he'll never know me like this
oh you can't actually you can't turn
your prop your are one direction always
though haha
oh crap really yeah we are this hey
let's just do this
so you don't see me moving turn around
right now I'm just static yeah you're
static oh I didn't know you could look
around while we were playing I thought I
had to stay still
yeah you can look around turn does this
look I don't know what we look like what
do we look awful awful he'd know in a
second there's no way you're been gonna
totally miss you I don't have it Wade if
you come in this room you fit and if you
don't well are you guys actually inside
yes we are horrible idea wasn't right
this isn't oh this you guys oh damn it
wow I can't buy health because it was
blending in in the light oh that was the
most obvious thing I could double I was
doing damage or not
Oh still beautiful way all right Wade
Huizar coming for you good luck shoot
you in the face nice are gonna get you a
deflation wait a minute for some reason
I'm excel $8.00 in vain yes about heck
was that I don't I don't know the
jar-jar Bain Chuck chirp a hand I got it
I can fit how in the world way do your
best Jar Jar Bane um give me a second to
think of how the oh you think the shadow
is growl ah no that's not no that's ha
ha ha
no mr. Wayne thing the darkness is your
ally ha ha ha
Bob you turn up then for you allowed to
die ah wait what'd you say what'd you
say to me go your best Jar Jar I'd be uh
uh uh it's hard yeah yeah no uh I saw
somebody nobody taking me seriously till
I put on this a mess ha ha ha ha ha I
love it
it was close but not I don't know ever
hey guys out there in the comments
section go if you can do a jar Jar Bane
but make a youtube video of it and send
to me I would love to hear I would love
to hear that if you can possibly
possibly make that come to life
eisah was born in the darkness eisah
eisah not me sir but eisah it's a
combination ha ha ha
Mesa was born in it no missile was born
the dollars raised in the darkness
Luther going a bit car dusted I can't I
saw somebody a while ago they were right
next to me are you in the basement Hey
well that's not how he flew at all I see
cars I heard some that's me throwing
crap around like a you see cars
you see cars are you outside the house
I'm like that no no there's a garage
there's a garage how the heck do I get
to the garage it's all through the
basement with the bar area you go down
into the garage you're in here aren't
you
mm-hmm where's the garage if you go
through the door at the bar there yeah
he's in here somewhere
you still gonna find me you sir gonna
get me get me get me oh hey Mark let's
do that same thing yeah let's do it
what's so good last time except
somewhere else
ah ah ah fine I'm gonna do it screw you
music in you sir not so close no more
about you better used to think the
laundry is your ally Audrey use the
that's as this is a clue whoa whoa I
heard it as below Oh Oh me so clue
because I saw you run to the corner ha
ha ha wait I'm in the baseball Wade what
I'm I'm in Bobby steamy
I said I was gonna I said I was gonna go
what all right whoa wait wait wait now
no downstairs downstairs I promise okay
and I'm I thought not gonna help you too
much more cuz it's up you when you see
it you'll I'm just not gonna say anymore
cuss words
Wow can get me where to go oh yeah get
the it get the monkey get the
bucket
what was I talking about what bucket or
get outside I am outside oh my god
Oh God Oh start with what was laundries
but mean I just laundry machine washing
machine the whole time okay
yeah that was this one the whole time
I'm uh I'm still back inside mmm I don't
believe you all right after all that
cheating that I did there's no way ha ha
cheating what when I was on the river
where you goin where D big wing you
going around the house I last see
outside yeah he's outside he's all
runnin yeah Wow
ahh are you outside I might be good see
this oh I can't see it anymore but oh no
Gilley
gosh darn it boy alright wait I'll give
you a hint mark you can keep your spot
if you want o was leaning up against the
house who's that he was tied to no yeah
yeah
but he was touching the house ah what
pal where'd you come from you drunk or
you dig you didn't see me before I'm
pretty quick thank you honey my hint was
too accurate yeah yeah all I had to do
is walk outside then he took off
Oh